sorry what was that thing you said 4
a.m. he did what he said he went oh okay
so oh my god last night I couldn't sleep
because I was so nervous yeah today so
forth I woke up and I looked at the
window okay okay so before Kylie moved
into my house okay
there's a gigantic window a sliding
glass door oh yeah right so I oh oh
someone died so I took black tape
blackboards in cardboard and I blocked
out the light oh so you can never even
open it it's just I don't want to open
it
that's where the outside is you know me
when I'm sleeping I want pitch-black nah
I don't I don't want to a beam of light
yeah it eights me okay it gets under my
skin skin
it's inches much vampire yeah well you
know but anyway um but then kalila when
I was on the road one night I'm not
fighting with you I'm just stating a
fact
all right well there's a balcony there
and we should have more alive I think it
has to do with my you know my mood the
darkness right so she tore all the
[ __ ] things go down right and then
now there's a little brown blanket I
mean that's on there and there's all
this light going through I can't sleep
so what did you do last night I was I
woke up but I took tape and I'm trying
to get the blanket back on using like
duct tape yeah hey snapchat like losing
his mind because my [ __ ] mind
it was four o'clock the Sun wasn't out
so he was because I was for seeing I can
feel the earth rotating and as the Sun
is coming within the next two hours he
felt it and I didn't want to meet it
yeah okay he was also just very anxious
so every movement that I made he but can
you turn the light off and like the
light is off if you would just make
these weird like and then I know you
hear that and then I open my eyes look
at her and she's just staring into her
phone but I don't know what you're
looking at I'm watching something on my
iPad no there was one point we're just
looking at a phone I don't know you
that's what people do on their phones is
look at it
usually all right what are you doing
phone not look at it for like an hour
just hold it and not look like this
right that's even weirder and then my
dog wants to sleep on my face what do
you mean she prefers to his the warmth
of his dirty head so she literally where
is it leaps oh my god like a hat you
know I had to pack damn it you know I
mean I get [ __ ] furious listen my
listen it's the leaf family as this man
you know being a slurp King right you
need sleep
it's app it's in the title if I don't
get 910 hours of deep sleep this trouble
on the way okay so tonight before I go
to bed tonight I'm gonna take this black
tape control with your name on the side
of it look at please return this is
black tape with other sizes please
return to George Kimmel why do you label
all the things you let's go for take
it's worth like 20 bucks 20 bucks here's
40 I'm taking it and I'm not accepting
it you're taking it I'm taking all this
tape though sweetie we do have all this
tape um for somebody who will easily
throw 40 bucks at the gentleman across
the way couldn't you just have invested
in some blackout blinds when you moved
in here if you hate the Sun so much I
don't know how to do that
preemie you just call company and say
I'm not calling I'm not calling nobody
but you should see what he actually uses
the light what do I use toys toys like
he buys in Troy
he bought a blank illustration board the
boxes of his toys three layers of
blanket aluminum it's like foil yeah you
play fallout man you know the bills
Jesse and that's the positivity I was
looking for you all day thank you right
there right there right there right now
that's gonna win with me okay okay that
positivity and that gleaming smile right
there look at me right now right now do
it right now you'll forget okay all that
you have a soft smile copy all right and
it seeps into my [ __ ] okay I love it
keep doing that [ __ ] yeah and you you
have another
incoming what do I have coming buttocks
put the [ __ ] thing back on what son
isn't gonna hear you Bobby
[Music]